>> PRESIDENT BIDEN FACING
INTENSE CRITICISM OVER THIS FLIP
SCREEN MOMENT WHERE HE WAS SEEN
BIKING ON VACATION WHILE IMAGES
OF A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS WITH
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS PACKED IN
SQUALLOR CONDITIONS UNDER A
BRIDGE.
AGENTS ARE WORKING TO REMOVE THE
MIGRANTS THAT ARE CAMPING OUT.
>> IF YOU COME TO THE UNITED
STATES ILLEGALLY, YOU WILL BE
RETURNED.
YOUR JOURNEY WILL NOT PROCEED
AND YOU WILL BE ENDANGERING YOUR
LIFE AND YOUR FAMILY'S LIVES.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO DEVELOPING SAFE ORDINARILY
AND HUMANE PATH WAYS FOR
MIGRATION BUT THIS IS NOT THE
WAY TO DO IT.
>> OKAY.
HE SAID THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
IF YOU WOULD SEE THIS FOOTAGE
FROM OVER THE WEEKEND WITH
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS JUST
WALKING ACROSS THE BORDER, THE
BORDER DOES NOT LOOK CLOSED.
AT WHAT POINT ARE WE GOING TO
GET THESE URGENT MEASURES HE IS
TALKING ABOUT?
IT IS NOW SEPTEMBER 20.
>> WE'RE NEVER GOING TO GET IT.
BIDEN IS NOT RUNNING THE
COUNTRY.
HE'S RUNNING IT INTO THE GROUND.
YOU CANNOT HAVE THIRD WORLD
PEOPLE AT OUR GATE.
HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO BRING
THIS COUNTRY BACK TO NORMAL.
THAT'S NOT NORMAL.
YOU CAN'T HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ON HORSEBACK TRYING TO ROUND UP
WAVES OF WEST AFRICANS AND
HAITIANS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
THAT'S CRAZINESS.
NOW HE'S HAD AUGUST AND
SEPTEMBER OF SHOCKING IMAGES,
ASSAULTING THE SENSES OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT WE WERE NOT
TOLD WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
JOE BIDEN WAS SUPPOSED TO GET A
HOLD ON THIS STUFF.
IT'S EXPLODED UNDER HIS WATCH.
IMAGINE WE DID THIS TO DELAWARE.
RIGHT?
IMAGINE WE SHIPPED THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS INTO
DELAWARE AND THEY'RE FISHING ON
THE BAY.
THEY'RE RIDING AMTRAK, PACKED IN
ON BACKS, LITTLE ENGLISH, NO
SKILLS.
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO LIVE?
IN TENTS AT THE BEACH?
ARE WE GOING TO PUT THEM IN
STARTER HOMES?
YOU'LL HAVE TO DOUBLE EVERY
CLASSROOM SIZE OF EVERY PUBLIC
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO RAISE
TAXES TO PAY FOR THE SOCIAL
SERVICES.
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED HEALTH
CARE, HOUSING, WELFARE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY'RE GOING TO STEAL JOBS,
LOWER WAGES AND IN A GENERATION
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE POLITICAL
POWER BECAUSE THEIR FAMILIES
WILL BE ABLE TO VOTE.
THAT WILL CHANGE THE ENTIRE
DIRECTION OF DELAWARE.
DO DELAWAREANS WANT THAT?
WHY IS JOE DOING THAT TO TEXAS.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ARE
SAYING, CLOSED DOWN, JOE.
SLOW IT DOWN, JOE.
HE SITS IN HIS BEACH HOUSE AND
OBSESSED OVER MASKS TO SLAP ON
2ND GRADERS.
>> THERE WAS AN EXCHANGE TODAY
THAT I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON.
THIS IS PETER DOOCY ASKING WHERE
IS THE VICE PRESIDENT?
>> WHERE'S THE VICE PRESIDENT ON
ANY OF THIS?
ISN'T SHE SUPPOSED TO BE CAUSING
THE ROOT CAUSES OF MIGRATION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SHE HAS BEEN ADDRESSING THE ROOT
CAUSES OF MIGRATION BY WORKING
WITH COUNTRIES IN THE REGION TO
ENSURE THEY HAVE TO ASSISTANCE
THEY NEED TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE COMING AND TRYING TO
MAKE THOSE JOURNEYS ACROSS THE
BORDER.
>> GREG, THIS WEEKEND ON
SATURDAY, KAMALA HARRIS WAS AT A
COLLEGE FOOTBALL GAME DOING THE
CEREMONIAL COIN TOSS.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A ROOT
CAUSE.
>> SHE WAS ROOTING INSTEAD OF
LOOKING FOR THE ROOT CAUSE.
HOW ABOUT OPENING A HAIR SALON
CALLED ROOT CAUSES IN CASE YOU
WANT A TOUCHUP.
>> IS IT REDUNDANT OR
PREFERABLE.
EVER HAVE A CO-WORKER, YOU'RE
DELIGHTED WHEN THEY TAKE A WEEK
OFF?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOREVER.
NO, THIS HAS NOT.
THIS REFUGEE CAMP, THAT'S NEW.
YOU GOT 13,000 PEOPLE IN A CITY
OF LIKE 20,000, 25,000.
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED.
WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED UNDER A
WATCHFUL ADMINISTRATION THAT
TAKES IMMIGRATION AND THE BORDER
SERIOUSLY.
I RETURNED THE FOX NEWS THIS
MORNING.
THE DRONE FOOTAGE HAS FORCED
THIS ISSUE.
NOT IN THE CNN STYLE OF PUSHING
DIVISIVENESS.
THIS IS NOT JUST A LEFT OR
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THIS IS VISUAL OF CHAOS AND
CALAMITY.
THESE PEOPLE WANT TO GET IN.
AFGHANISTAN, THEY WANTED TO GET
OUT.
FORCES YOU TO ASK QUESTIONS.
WOULD THIS EVER HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED IF IT WASN'T FOR THE
NETWORK PROVIDING THESE VISUALS?
THE ANSWER IS NO.
NO ONE ELSE BOTHERED TO DO IT.
WE REALIZED THEN THE CONCLUSION
TO MY LONG AND PAINFUL THOUGHT
IS THAT REAL JOURNALISM ONLY
EXISTS IF YOU HATE THE
PRESIDENT.
RIGHT?
THAT'S WHY NONE OF THESE
NETWORKS ARE BOTHERING TO DO IT.
THEY WOULD ONLY DO IT ABOUT
TRUMP.
IF THEY'RE ON THE BIDEN TEAM,
THEY'RE NOT GONNA DO THIS STORY.
WE WERE AT THE BORDER UNDER
TRUMP AND UNDER BIDEN, AND THIS
NETWORK IS PRODUCING PULITZER
PRIZE WINNING VISUALS THERE AND
THEY WILL NOT GET REWARDED FOR
IT.
LASTLY, ON GOING EDUCATION.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE FRESH NEWS.
>> THE MAYOR OF DEL RIO, THE
TOWN WHERE THIS IS HAPPENING.
SHE SAID SHE WAS TRYING TO GET
AHOLD OF THE WHITE HOUSE OVER
THE WEEKEND AND DIDN'T GET A
CALL BACK.
I GUESS VISIT FROM THE DIRECTOR
OF HOMELAND SECURITY TODAY.
THAT SEEMS A LITTLE LIKE YOU'RE
NOT DOING YOUR JOB.
>> IT'S AN EMERGENCY LEVEL, SAME
LEVEL AFTER YOU'VE HAD A
HURRICANE.
SAME LEVEL WHERE YOU NEED FEMA
ON THE PHONE AND THEY NEED TO
TALK TO THE ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN A CITY OF
25,000 AND THERE ARE 13,000 NEW
PEOPLE UNDER A BRIDGE.
WHEN I FIRST SAW THE FOOTAGE,
FRIDAY THE DRONES STARTED
OPERATING AGAIN.
I SAID THIS DOESN'T NORMALLY
LOOK LIKE IT NORMALLY DOES.
THEN I THOUGHT HOW DO THOUSANDS
OF HAITIANS END UP THERE?
WENT AND READ ABOUT IT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ENTERED IN
2010 AFTER THE EARTHQUAKE.
THEY WORKED MOSTLY IN BRAZIL
UNTIL THE RIO GAMES WHEN JOBS
DRIED UP THERE AND WERE SLOWLY
MIGRATING.
IT'S A NEW IMMIGRATION PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE NOT BEEN TALKING
ABOUT UNDER ANY ADMINISTRATION.
>> ONE OF THEM, I READ THIS
ARTICLE ABOUT A HAITIAN WHO
IMMIGRATED TO CHILE.
HAD BEEN IN CHILE.
THEN HE SAID HE HEARD BIDEN WAS
LETTING PEOPLE IN.
SO HE JOINED FOLKS AND THEY GET
ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEN HE FINDS HIMSELF ON A
DEPORTATION FLIGHT BECAUSE
THEY'RE SENDING THOSE SINGLE
YOUNG MEN.
HE GOES BACK TO HAITI BUT HE
HADN'T EVEN BEEN IN HAITI.
>> ON THAT DEPORTATION FLIGHT
OVER THE WEEKEND, THERE WERE 300
INDIVIDUAL MEN BUT THERE WERE
3300 MIGRANTS WHO HAD BEEN MOVED
OUT FROM UNDER THE BRIDGE
FRIDAY.
WHERE ARE THE OTHER 3,000 OR SO?
SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY?
WHO KNOWS WHERE.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS MAYBE THEY
WERE WATCHING IN CHILE OR BRAZIL
OR OTHER COUNTRIES, JOE BIDEN
STANDING ON A STAGE WITH OTHER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES TWO
YEARS AGO RAISING HIS HAND
SAYING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE
GOING TO GET GOVERNMENT
HEALTHCARE.
THEN THEY REMOVE ALL OF THE
BORDER PROTECTION ONCE THEY TOOK
OFFICE.
PEOPLE IN THIS ADMINISTRATION
WERE TOLD BY TRUMP OFFICIALS,
HERE'S THE ROAD MAP ON HOW TO
STOP ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AT THE
BORDER.
CLEARLY, BIDEN AND COMPANY HAVE
BEEN WILLING TO USE THEIR VAST
EXECUTIVE POWER FOR THEIR OWN
POLITICAL BENEFIT WHEN THEY SEE
FIT.
WHEN THEY THINK THE CAUSE IS
WORTHY.
THEY DIDN'T LET THE ABORTION LAW
IN TEXAS TO SAVE MORE BABIES
FROM DYING SO THEY UNLEASHED
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT TO CHANGE
THINGS THEY DIDN'T LIKE.
JOE BIDEN WAS WILLING TO
OVERSTEP HIS EXECUTIVE POWER
KNOWINGLY ON THOSE MORATORIUMS.
IT WAS BRAZEN LAWLESSNESS.
THEY ADMITTED IT.
THEY DID IT ANYWAY.
BUT THIS IS OKAY WITH THEM.
HUMAN SUFFERING AND MISERY.
AND FINANCIAL BURDENS AND HEALTH
BURDENS PUT ON THE CITIZENS OF
THE UNITED STATES WHO LIVE IN
THESE BORDER COMMUNITIES.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT PROMOTING SUFFERING.
>> WHAT DO YOU CALL THIS?
>> THE ABORTION BILL.
THAT IS SO OUT OF THE MAIN
STREAM THAT 70% OF REPUBLICANS
DON'T SUPPORT IT.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW YOU ARE
PREGNANT IN A LOT OF CASES BY
SIX WEEKS.
>> THERE ARE CHILDREN SUFFERING
AT THE BORDER AND IT HAS BEEN
GOING ON ALL YEAR.
WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
NOTHING.
RIDING HIS BIKE AROUND